[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es einen wunsch rezept von
einer freundin die hat sich nämlich eine
mandarine und schmand kuchen gewünscht
dem sie immer ganz gerne aus der packung
gemacht hat und sehr lang sagt sally
komm du kannst das auch ohne packung
bitte zeigt mir wie es geht
und jetzt habe ich dir hier gebacken
unten ist ein rührteig denn ein bisschen
fester ist also so zwischen ruhr und in
der mitte habe ich die schmandt massa
mit pudding und obendrauf die mandarinen
mit einem schönen tortenguss der
ausgebrachte von ich muss erst mal
wusste ich nicht dass du überhaupt
freunde hast es ist er ist ja ich hab
keine freunde wie sich mein spruch das
sage ich auch keine freunde mehr durch
dich will ich ja nicht mehr entkommen
muss ja ja nur am essen wir uns das
zweite was ich sagen wollte
ich habe meinem leben ist es ist der
wahnsinn jetzt sagen die zuschauer
wieder hey natürlich lobte seine frau
aber ich habe noch nie so einen bus
gesehen wirklich nicht aus als wäre
wasser drauf ist es halt ich habe den
tortenguss mit agar agar gemacht also
mit pflanzlichem geliermittel und wenn
man den tortenguss aus der packung kennt
der muss so ein bisschen trüb also der
ist nicht ganz durchsichtig und so
wird's echt viel schöner aus was ich
finde ja erstmal nachher richtig auch
wenn das läuft ja noch nie gesehen tom
heute ausnahmsweise einmal richtig auch
mal richtig drehen
das sind fünf jahren ausbildung ja ich
zeige euch jetzt zuerst einmal die
zutaten ich fange jetzt zuerst mit dem
pudding an da muss nämlich schön
abkühlen für den pudding brauch ich 500
milliliter milch 45 kommt stärke 100
gramm zucker und einen teelöffel vanille
extrakt jetzt verrühren ich zuerst die
stärke mit etwas milch in einem kleinen
topf und führte dann die restliche milch
dazu jetzt kommen noch zucker und
vanille extrakt mit rein und ich kann
dem maße gut verrühren und dann bei
höchster stufe einmal aufkochen lassen
nach dem aufkochen lasse ich den pudding
eine minute einkochen und dann fühle ich
ihn um damit er schön abkühlen kann
und damit sich keine haut darüber bildet
werde ich ihnen jetzt mit
frischhaltefolie abdecken und dann
vollständig abkühlen lassen
für den rückbau bis 50 gramm gehobelte
mandeln 75 gramm pro tag 75 gramm zucker
etwas vanille extrakt ein zimmer warmes
150 gramm mehl 1 teelöffel backpulver
und eine prise salz sei als normal nehme
ich jetzt die geholten mandeln die
kommen nämlich unter den teig das heißt
die hälfte davon
ich gebe ich jetzt hier bereits in meine
backform habe ich jetzt einen tortenring
auf etwa 26 cm schon eingestellt und die
hälfte speicher auf die kommt nämlich
über den teig und jetzt kann ich schon
die weiche butter nehmen und in die
rührschüssel geben
[Musik]
da kommt der zucker mit dazu und etwas
vanille extrakt dann kann ich die masse
für etwa drei bis vier minuten cremig
rühren
[Musik]
sobald die butter maße cremig gerührt
ist kommt jetzt bei niedriger stufe noch
das ei mit rein und wird eine minute mit
gerührt
jetzt kann ich doch das mehl mit dem
backpulver und dem salz vermischen und
kann das ganz kurz einrühren und wer
möchte kann den teig auch ein bisschen
aromatisieren mit einem esslöffel rum
zum beispiel
und jetzt kommt der teig direkt auf den
mandeln drauf und dann wieder glatt
gestrichen und das geht am besten wenn
ihr die hände einfach ein bisschen nass
macht und damit und fingern denn klappt
und dann mit den fingern den teig glatt
streichen wollte ich das sagen
zum glück hat meine mutter nicht als
kind zum teig sauber gehabt ich glaube
ich hätte ich war immer sauer gewesen
wenn die schüssel so leer gewesen wäre
bei mir als ich dann zum ausschlagen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier die mandeln auch
schon drauf
der pudding ist auch bereits abgekühlt
und den werde ich jetzt hier einmal kurz
7 damit einfach die klümpchen
verschwinden
und jetzt brauche ich nur noch vier
zutaten für die creme und zwar habe ich
jetzt hier 400 gramm schmandt 250 gramm
magerquark 1 1 und 2 dosen mandarinen
und da habe ich den saft bereits
abtropfen lassen und ihn aufgefangen und
jetzt kann ich hier einfach die zutaten
reingeben somit zum pudding und schwupps
und das ei für die bindung und die
zutaten ganz kurz berühren
[Musik]
und jetzt verteidigt die pudding creme
über dem teig und über den mandeln
darüber verteile ich jetzt die
mandarinen und dann kann der kuchen
schon gebacken werden
[Musik]
der käse corinne ist gebacken und ich
habe ihn jetzt komplett abkühlen lassen
ich hatte ihn auch im kühlschrank und
jetzt ist er wirklich sehr schön
er glänzt aber noch mehr wenn da jetzt
noch eine zuckerschicht rüber kommt also
ein bus und dafür habe ich jetzt in
mandarin saft aufgefangen und lassen dem
top 250 milliliter von mandarinen sagt
mit fünf gramm agha aufkochen und zwei
minuten lang sprudelnd kochen und jetzt
habe ich sie den fertigen kunst den habe
ich ganz kurz abkühlen lassen
damit das so ein bisschen wärmer als
lauwarm ist und den gis ich jetzt hier
drüber
und so kommt der kuchen noch mal in den
kühlschrank besteck aspekte jetzt ist
der tortenguss fest und ich habe den
kuchen aus der form gelöst und agatha
wird auch schneller fest als fertiger
tortenguss also da hat mal eine
zeitersparnis und ankara das wissen die
meisten hat sich dann wie kaka war ja
aber das ist rein pflanzlich kenne also
auch für veganer geeignet nur der bus
bahn und jemanden reden also denn ich
hatte ja dann ist nun also liebe wigan
auch wieder nur linken setzen und die
mandarin group sieht aus als hätte ich
ein eis aufgebrochen gemacht so cool
thomas muster ist noch mal aufgenommen
haben
knopf gedrückt was mich an das was da
genau los ist ein russisches ein
bisschen eine kindische jüdische
mitbürger erklärt mal um den kommentaren
was ein russisches gas als schotter
abschnitt wird das schön
darf ich jetzt ja nicht du darfst okay
köstlich wirklich schmeckt dir wirklich
super dass ein standard schön mal oben
oder ganz starken kamera mit leuten die
zuschauer wissen das ist heute schon
fertigung und ist ja wir wollen ja mal
hinten in die ecke vom wohnzimmer eine
gopro anbringen so für die berühmte
sehen und dann schaut echt schon das
vierte rezept aber kann es sein dass er
von niemandem gemacht
ja genau auf dem boden genau da habe ich
nochmal alles ist gleich gehabt warum
das gemacht ja damit es knackig wird
echt und damit des jahres ist muss es
sein mit dem man will muss nicht warum
du magst du noch immer ja aber die sind
ziemlich dunkel die man machen kann ist
aber den leuten mal den boden von buchen
sein dann mache ich so lange darin gar
nichts halber siehst du das kommt war
okay jetzt noch nicht gesehen egal wie
geschichten sind ist nun mal als 234
mantel und einem rührteig schmandt von
tränen trocknen muss also wissen sie
dass sie nochmals und falls ihr das
rezept nach machen wollte nachsehen
dann könnt ihr das auch sally blog
nachlesen und da steht noch mal alles
ganz genau ich freue mich auf euren
gucken vielleicht schickt er mir auch
ein foto und postet es auf facebook oder
instagram und wir schauen dann natürlich
auch nach also viel spaß am backen und
bis zum nächsten mal
ich glaube heute habe ich mal so worauf
[Musik]